what kind of europe do you want to live
in
the conference on the future of europe
is your chance to have a say
the inaugural plenary took place at the
european parliament in strasbourg
i see this conference in fact has a
relay race citizens participating in
panels
will formulate their recommendations and
then over
several plenaries of the conference they
will hand over the pattern
and we will together with them formulate
concrete proposals
for reform it's about time that we build
our future together
our common feature let's make this
exercise
the best that we can it's a true
genuine process of real engagement with
our citizens
the parliament's delegation set out
ambitious priorities
they want the conference to reach
citizens that normally wouldn't
participate in a project like this
the plenary involves representatives
from the eu institutions
national and regional authorities social
partners and civil society
as well as citizens from all corners of
the union
plenaries are just one of the three
pillars of the conference
there is the multilingual online
platform which lets you share your ideas
and endorse other people's proposals
on the issues that matter to you the
economy
education migration culture climate
change
then there are the pan-european citizens
panels they will meet to discuss
suggestions put forward on the platform
from october citizens from these panels
will speak directly with european
representatives at conference plenary
sessions
to mould these ideas into actionable
proposals
for the first time ever you the citizens
have this conference and or on an equal
footing with your
elected representatives you are not
replacing representative democracy but
reinforcing it
by bringing citizens into the heart of
policy making in the european union
the european parliament has pledged that
the conference will have a tangible
impact on eu policy